Her low freak bitches,
but I do.
I do feel like the country is
divided to a point of like,
I don't know, we're not going
to be honest. Again, it's not,
it doesn't seal on the
Internet. It's bad. I got my,
I got my news a lot from the daily show.
What I would watch the
daily show and I would see,
I feel like Jon Stewart is a
obviously a very left leaning guy,
but he's also a very smart guy in a very
funny guy and when he would talk about
like events in the news and mock them
and show clips and mock the clips,
that to me is a way better
version of what I would get.
Like I can discern what's a joke,
I can discern how he's making fun,
but then I will also get the
actual information of these
events from him as well.
That to me is a way better version of
news entertainment than what fucking CNN
is doing.
Cause with CNN is doing is having s
what are essentially actors like really
boring people that are reading some
stupid shit off a teleprompter.
Like you take fucking Anderson
Cooper away from the news. What?
Who was Anderson Cooper? What do you,
are you interesting dude? You know what?
Let's have him talk. Have him give a
speech somewhere. Have him talk to people,
have him have him do, do a standup
routine. He's boring as shit. I bet.
You know what I'm saying to me that if
you're watching an entertainer give you
the news, which is essentially
what CNN is doing, right?
Fucking John Stewart should be on CNN.
Yeah.
But then he'd have to like
go to work every day. He
didn't want to do that. Right.
Is that what he's, his deal is he
doesn't want to work and you know, he,
I mean he doesn't want the daily
show after so many years. I mean,
I was there for a lunch. I talked to John
a lot. I think a lot of it is just the,
the feeling of like, you know, doing
it a talk show four nights a week,
every day and calling
through all that news.
Like we were giving people the little
golden nuggets that happened throughout
the day. But like we have
to watch it. Like, you know,
we were absorbing a lot of like radiation
from all that stuff and like, you know,
like the closer you yard of the radiation,
the more you know your,
your hair gets grade, your soul hurts
after a while. And I think for John,
I mean I, I think him leaving when
he left, it was a good way to do it.
You just make a bunch of money and say, oh
that's it. No, it wasn't even the money.
I think it was just, he felt like,
and he said it on the last show.
I wasn't there for the, I mean I, I'd
stopped working there before he retired,
but I think he just got to
a point where he said like,
I'm not doing this at the
level I could do it at anymore.
Therefore someone else should do
it. Like he was telling, he used,
he was just kind of, he did it, you know.
And I think if you waited through
this election, which people were like,
I wish she was to align. It's like, yeah,
but now Trump would be in
and then everyone would be
like, you can't quit. No try.
You know, like he'd be, he'd be
stuck in it forever, you know?
And I think he just wanted to walk away
like on the top, you know, like the way,
you know, like a retire after a super
bowl win kind of thing. You know,
people forget that he wasn't the original
host. Isn't that fascinating? Yeah.
At Kilborne was, yeah. What
happened to that guy? I don't know.
I never worked there with Kilborne.
I started like six months after
John Stewart started and uh,
so I've heard a lot of like
funny Kilborne stories.
Like he was a good dude and
he was a really funny guy.
But like definitely much more of
a read the teleprompter. Yeah.
Read what they put in. The
prompts are kind of, you
know, Raga Ron Burgundy style,
you know, fuck yourself. San
Diego. Yeah. Great job with, uh,
John. When John came on and he was
like really a writer, producer mind.
There was definitely like a sea change
at the shadow of like the writers.
The original writers go on
like, what the hell? Hey Buddy,
don't ruin our little
show. And he was like, man,
I don't know if you understand how
this is going to work. You know?
There was a little girl, there was like
a clash a little bit, a little bit.
What was their vision that he was just
going to read whatever they wrote? Yeah.
Period. Yeah, I think so. But
he's a really funny comic.
Why wouldn't they want him to contribute
and make it funnier? Right? Yeah.
I don't know. I mean, it
worked out in his favor.
I think his contributions ended up making
the show pretty down, honestly. Yeah.
But Egos are a motherfucker, man.
It's fun. It's always an odd thing.
Okay.